they felt
cheated by their exam results trust our
teachers
hours before the government newton these
students
took their anger on the march making
their way to the office of their local
mp
the education secretary gavin williamson
among the pupils affected will lloyd who
was predicted 2a stars and an
a but awarded abc meaning he lost his
place to study medicine at lancaster
university
when i opened the envelope i was
absolutely devastated really
um i was hoping that i'd be at
university in september
registered study medicine and i'd be the
first person in my family to do that
katie cross was predicted aab but
awarded
bbc and missed out on her place at
liverpool university
yeah i feel really let down and just
i think you're in like a situation that
you can't imagine being put in
i don't think you prepare to be
downgraded
by so much especially knowing how hard i
worked and
the effort that i've put in and monica
lewis who has predicted
ccc but awarded cde
having those grades on my cv is going to
affect my chance of getting a job going
up against
other people who may have better grades
than what i was given due to the use of
the algorithm
their protest over back at school they
waited anxiously for the government
announcement
this is our news today it's four o'clock
we start this hour with breaking news
after five days of inaction the
government's u-turns on gcse
how do you feel that it's taken so long
for this u-turn to happen you've had
days now
of uncertainty and upset yeah i think
that um it's brilliant that it has
finally happened i mean it shouldn't
have taken as long as it had
now their predicted grades stand are
there still
spaces left on their courses ucas
haven't messaged me the uni haven't
so i'll ring and find out will's already
on the phone
but the news on his place at medical
school is mixed so not necessarily this
year but definitely next year
okay how does that make you feel given
that you got the grave yeah
it is irritating to know that i have got
in but just
it's more waiting the class of 2020 have
faced
so many challenges this u-turn may have
come
too late for some to follow their chosen
path
becky johnson sky news codzilla